so how do you remember which ones which
let's have a got these examples quickly
together really the key is just to add
in alphabetical order right u over V
okay to this day I still write the U and
the V even though it's pretty easy to
see it's not a huge amount of
information that gets added on there but
it just gives you a metal tag when
you're doing your vu - Midas UV - over V
squared you know exactly which one is
which
okay let's have a go there it is there's
the rule if it makes you feel better
write it out again just to help it get
into your brain a little bit what's V in
this case 3x plus 2
what's u - there's use so what's you -
what I'm going to highly encourage you
to write the fact that it's one even
though it doesn't make a difference
because it shows that you're actually
going through the question rule I on the
top it's a minus and then what's you X
plus 1 V - just 3 all divided by V
squared okay let's just tidy up a little
bit cuz as you can see that numerator
can be you know you've got to click the
model like terms up there so you're
going to get a 3x plus two out the front
- 3 X + 3 ya look good all divided by I
will point out at this stage that
there's always certainly nothing to gain
by expanding the denominator and you
always get something down here that's
squared but like what do you want
advantage is that I turn that into 9 x
squared + 12 X + 4 there's no gate at
all there's no extra information that
you can do that you can see from it so I
just leave it like so and that looks
like we get this and you're home and
host ok any questions on that
not nearly as bad not nearly as bad okay
now before we finish off and I just let
you use there are many Pylea tied to
finish off 7f 4 start 7g the the main
thing to watch out for here in to be
conscious of is that the proto-tool as
you can see it's a fair bit of work it's
a fair bit of work so the main thing
about the proportion rule is actually
when not to use the question rule you'll
see questions and your instinct will be
to use the question rule but you
shouldn't always in fact whenever you
can you should avoid it because it's a
mess of it's just terrible like it just
on and on and on it goes right so when
you look at talking like this it's a
question but you don't have to write
this particular one it's a question have
a look what could you do this before you
start differentiating okay so and you
can see that you can divide each of
these terms by X like each of them
independently so this is going to become
well x squared divided by X is just it's
just X right
well first day back guys okay and then
as was pointed out 4 over X I would
write that for differentiation purposes
I will write that as 4 X to the negative
1 and then off you go no question rule
quiet just treat each one individually
ok
in the same way you could do this using
the question rule if you have a death
wish an easier way to do it is simply to
say hey look you've got a whole figure
that's on the bottom of the denominator
right every time you see something on
the bottom right you write it in index
form because that's always easier for
the purposes of differentiation so how
would I write this in the next world now
you're still out of the woods you're
still gonna have to do chain rule on
that the chain rule is tons easier than
question rule in fact pretty much
everything is easier than course should
rule okay so I use quotient rule when
you have two and tamiya so it's not that
bad again it's quite similar to the
product rule which is by so the the tax
on your memory is not disastrous but if
there's another way like I think we can
agree that these are more efficient
paths through the quest
so don't just jump straight to
differentiation okay think about what
you can do with that thing before you
actually start the process and then off
you go
okay